[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la course au vaccin
contre le coc u19 devenu un enjeu à la
fois scientifique sanitaires et
géopolitique cette compétition à
l'échelle planétaire bat son plein
aujourd'hui un ampli quand les
principales puissances mondiales ou 1 et
tombe donc dans cette recherche qui
pourrait mettre fin à la pandémie
le 14 octobre la russie annonce
l'enregistrement du deuxième vaccin anti
kovy devenant ainsi le leader mondial
dans cette course les états unis la
talonne les laboratoires américains
développent deux vaccins qui en sont à
la dernière étape des essais cliniques
la chine elle commence déjà la
vaccination de masse en que l'étape
finale des essais soit terminé selon les
prévisions de la ms au moins un vaccin
sera approuvée par l'organisation d'ici
la fin de l'année
seul problème nombre de pays à hauts
revenus représentant seulement 13 % de
la population mondiale ont déjà mis la
main sur plus de la moitié des doses des
principaux fabricants afin d'assurer
l'accès équitable au vaccin
le ms lance un dispositif mondial c'est
l'initiative actes
elle vise à développer un rom est
universellement accessible l'action de
ce groupe est financé par les membres
parmi lesquels sont quatorze pays
développés l'union européenne et
d'autres organisations
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur ce long chemin qui
sépare la formule des vaccins des
produits finis c'est le blick ce en
général la mise au point d'un vaccin en
prend entre sept et dix ans pourtant
avec le comique 19
les chercheurs du monde entier se voit
obligée de réduire cette durée un an ou
deux ans seulement
tout commence par des essais dits pré
clinique ceci se déroule en laboratoire
sur des morceaux de tissus humains et
animaux puis directement sur des animaux
une fois que ces essais sont validées le
vaccin peut passer aux essais cliniques
qui se déroule eux en trois étapes
d'abord on l'administré un groupe de 10
à 100 de personnes si tout se passe bien
on élargit ensuite le nombre de
personnes jusqu'à plusieurs centaines
enfin la troisième phase consiste à
tester le vaccin à grande échelle sur
plusieurs milliers de personnes en cas
de succès le vaccin se fait enregistrer
auprès d'une instance nationale ou
internationale
à ce jour plus de 200 candidats vaccins
contre le comique 19 sont à l'étude à
travers le monde et plus de 60 d'entre
eux en sont à l'étape des essais
cliniques
enfin seulement une dizaine de vaccins
passe la toute dernière étape
il s'agit des traitements fabriquées aux
états unis en chine en russie et au
royaume uni depuis le début de la
pandémie due nouveau coronavirus les
principales puissances mondiales
poursuivre une course acharnée contre la
montre pour trouver un vaccin contre le
coc u19 leader actuel dans cette
compétition la russie déclarent avoir
enregistré deux vaccins c'est le
spoutnik v et vector il passe
actuellement
la dernière phase des essais cliniques
aux états unis le 6 octobre l'agencé
américaine des médicaments publié de
nouvelles règles qui oblige les
producteurs des vaccins attendre au
moins deux mois après l'injection de la
dernière dose lors des essais cliniques
une réglementation qui rend fort
improbable l'apparition d'un vaccin
américain avant l'élection
présidentielle
l'autre poids lourd dans cette
compétition la chine n'a pas encore fini
l'étape 3d et cliniques
autorise déjà la vaccination de masse
tenant compte de l'ampleur inédite de
cette course mais ce qu'on le choisir au
moins un vaccin anti covit d'ici fin
2020 pour le délivrer une autorisation
de commercialisation pourtant il ne sera
pas facile de le distribuer à tout le
monde car les plus grandes puissances
économiques ont déjà réservé plus de la
moitié de tous les vaccins disponibles à
l'horizon comment le nuc ont-elles
résoudre le problème de l'accessibilité
aux vaccins qui a plus de chances de
remporter cette course
enfin comment le ms comptaient lutter
contre la pandémie
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons nathalie comptines et
économiste de la santé à l'université
sorbonne-paris nar madame poutine et
bonjour bonjour tout d'abord est ce que
selon vous les vaccins contre le coc u19
seront vraiment l'euromed pour vaincre
enfin le virus seront ils à la hauteur
de nos attentes
l'un pour le moment pas vraiment pour le
moment c'est plutôt une couverture une
protection allant de 50% mais il n'y a
pas encore de vaccin qui montrerait une
efficacité plus importante
donc c'est pas tout à fait le vaccin
comme on a l'habitude de le connaître
c'est à dire qui offre une couverture
parfaite contre 1,50
vous avez dit 50% c'est 50% qui couvrent
quoi et qui empêcheraient à peu près à
moitié avec une chance sur deux de ne
pas attraper la maladie une chance sur
deux ça veut dire qu'il donne une
immunité de courte durée quand même ou
pas du tout
l'un pour le moment c'est pas et sans
doute qu'il faudra deux injections et
pas une seule donc effectivement c'est
pas des vaccins qui sont parfaits et
d'ailleurs la vie aux états unis qui est
l'organisme qui habilite les vaccins à
et les médicaments a dit qu'elle
n'accepterait pas un vaccin qui serait
prêt à offrir une couverture plus faible
que la moitié c'est donc pour le moment
on n'est pas sur des vaccins qui sont
très efficaces d'accord parlons
maintenant du premier vaccin enregistré
le spoutnik v pensez vous que les
critiques et d'une partie de la
communauté internationale envers le
vaccin russe soit vraiment fondées
disons que
le problème avec ce vaccin c'est que
pendant longtemps il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup d'informations concernant ce
vaccin
et puis beaucoup pensent qu'en fait on
est en phase de test 3com finalement
beaucoup d'autres vaccins on a
aujourd'hui une dizaine de ce qu'on
appelle des candidats vaccins qui sont
sur des passes de test à grande échelle
mais pour lesquels on n'a pas encore
suffisamment de recul pour être sûr que
ce sont des vaccins à la fois non
dangereux non toxique et efficace au
delà de la volonté de vaincre rapidement
cette pandémie la course au vaccin pour
vous c'est un prestige surtout
géopolitique ou plutôt avant tout
l'intérêt commercial aujourd'hui on va
bien sûr que les deux sont entremêlées
le pays qui sera le premier à mettre un
accent sur le marché un vaccin efficace
pour en revendiquer que c'est le plus
les avancées d'un point de vue
technologique que sa recherche et
développement et au haut niveau
donc il ya évidemment un enjeu
géopolitique mais il ya aussi bien sûr
un enjeu économique puisque ça va être
des milliards d'individus à vacciner est
donc un marché gigantesque
merci beaucoup madame comptines et nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons en fin
d'émission
pour plus de détails sur la question
merci le vaccin anti copie 19 américain
ne pourra pas être enregistré avant les
élections présidentielles c'est la
conséquence de la nouvelle
réglementation adoptée le 6 octobre par
l'agencé américaine des médicaments
elle oblige les fabricants à attendre au
moins deux mois après l'injection de la
dernière dose dans les essais cliniques
ce n'est qu'après qu'ils pourront
soumettre une demande de
commercialisation
et si la maison blanche comptait
initialement sur la mi octobre ou début
novembre pour présenter son nouveau
succès aujourd'hui elle se voit obligée
de reporter cette date au début 2021 et
tout cela provoque une vive réaction du
président américain qui considère cette
décision comme une action purement
politique
les nouvelles règles de la fda en plus
difficile pour eux d'accélérer
l'approbation des vaccins avant le jour
du scrutin
juste un nouveau coup politique en
pratique ces nouvelles règles n'affecte
aucunement le travail des laboratoires
américains qui mobilise tout leur savoir
faire
il y actuellement trois entreprises
américaines du secteur biomédical qui
sont au stade avancé de recherche
moderna pfizer et johnson & johnson
les deux premières mais leurs essais
depuis fin juillet prévoit la
vaccination de 30000 et 44 mille
participants et respectivement johnson &
johnson quand elle est entrée dans la
phase finale
fin septembre cependant le 12 octobre le
géant biomédicale s'est vu obligé
d'arrêter ses essais à cause d'une
maladie inconnue chez l'un de ses
participants
tout comme les états unis les autres
poids lourds géopolitique accélère aussi
dans la course au vaccin
la première annonce officielle est venue
de la russie qui a annoncé en août
l'enregistrement du premier vaccin
contre le coc vie 19 le spoutnik vue ce
matin pour la première fois au monde un
vaccin contre le nouveau coronavirus a
été enregistré je sais qu'il est assez
efficace qu'il donne une immunité
durable on aura besoin de vaccin et il
ya un espoir d'avoir peut-être un vaccin
vers la fin de l'année il y a un espoir
développé par le centre de recherche
gamaleya le vaccin spoutnik vais a passé
avec succès la première et la deuxième
phase des essais cliniques
il a été testé sur 76 individus parmi
lesquels une des filles du président
russe
selon ce dernier le 12 août la troisième
étape de l'étude a commencé plus de
40000 russes mais aussi des volontaires
en arabie saoudite au brésil au mexique
aux émirats arabes unis et dans d'autres
pays y participent
parallèlement aux essais la russie
prévoit de commencer la vaccination de
masse vers la fin de l'année
tout juste après l'enregistrement une
partie de la communauté internationale
commence à mettre en doute la fiabilité
du traitement russe en septembre les
chercheurs russes réplique en publiant
une
étude dans la prestigieuse revue
scientifique 2nd set après vérification
par un comité de scientifiques
indépendants
cette étude des livres de nombreux
éclaircissements sur le vaccin rassure
sur les effets secondaires et donnent
des résultats encourageants pour kirill
dmitriev directeur du fonds souverains
russes qui a financé le projet les
progrès russes ne peuvent plus être mise
en doute
la publication d'un hollande 7 constitue
une réponse puissante aux sceptiques qui
ont critiqué de manière déraisonnable le
bateau russe pourtant spoutnik n'est pas
le seul vaccin russe en cours de
développement le deuxième est élaborée
par le centre national de virologie et
de biotechnologie vector après avoir
passé les essais de la première et
deuxième phase il est enregistré en
octobre par les autorités russes
enfin le troisième vaccin russe est
développé par le centre fédéral de
médicaments immuno biologique tchoumakov
ces chercheurs en sont toujours aux
premières étapes décès qu'il compte
achever pour le mois de novembre avec de
multiples candidats au vaccin la
situation de la russie est semblable à
celle de la chine où plusieurs
laboratoires mène une compétition
acharnée pour mettre au point le vaccin
contre le coc vie de 19,1 des favoris de
la course serait ce le géant
pharmaceutique chinois sinopharm qui
développe deux vaccins expérimentaux en
phase iii des essais cliniques
les chercheurs prévoient de terminer les
essais d'ici la fin de l'année
deux autres groupes de recherche des
talonne sinovac et cansino et il devrait
être opérationnel début 2000 21
néanmoins les autorités chinoises sont
impatientes et la vaccination de masse a
déjà commencé plus de trois cent
cinquante mille personnes ont déjà reçu
le vaccin
en plus de ceux qui ont participé aux
essais cliniques
une précipitation qui inquiète une
partie de la communauté internationale
selon le washington post le vaccin
chinois peut représenter un danger
l'article raconte le cas d'un patient
chinois qui
s'est senti mal après l'injection de la
deuxième dose de ce vaccin
un autre média américain foxnews accuse
pékin d'une grave violation des règles
éthiques
la raison le groupe de recherche chinois
sinovac affirme avoir injecté le vaccin
à 90% de ses employés et à des proches
sans que la fiabilité du traitement soit
prouvée un des leaders de cette course
au vaccin la chine est talonné par
nombre d'autres centres de recherche qui
développent leur propre traitement par
exemple l'université d'oxford et son
partenaire industriel
astrazeneca en sont actuellement à la
dernière étape des essais et prévoit de
les terminer vers la fin 2020 ou début
2000 21
enfin le géant pharmaceutique allemand
curve ac commence fin septembre la
deuxième phase des essais cliniques
alors que la course au vaccin bat son
plein un énorme problème se dessine à
l'horizon celui de l'accessibilité du
traitement anti copie comment le nuc
comptait le faire face à ce défi quelle
est l'ampleur du problème
et enfin quel est l'enjeu économique de
la course au vaccin
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie les
laboratoires du monde entier sont sur le
pied de guerre pour mettre au point un
vaccin contre le colis 19 et aujourd'hui
le redouble d'efforts le virus est loin
d'avoir épuisé ses forces et continue de
faire des ravages dans tous les coins du
monde
selon l' oms le nombre de cas de corona
virus au monde dépasse 40 millions or le
dépistage encore imparfait et risque de
minimiser ces chiffres
l'om est elle-même là vous en octobre en
réalité jusqu'à 780 millions de
personnes auraient déjà été infectées
quant aux victimes du virus la barre
mondiale d'un million de morts a été
franchi fin septembre selon les chiffres
officiels à l'exception invraisemblable
de la corée du nord et quelques îlots
isolés la pandémie touche tous les pays
mais l'impact n'est pas uniforme
en effet 70% des cas confirmés sont
concentrés dans 10 pays
pire encore les trois premiers pays
totalisent la moitié de tous les cas
mondiaux
les etats unis sont en tête du
classement depuis le 11 avril soit
depuis plus de six mois
ce fiasco interminable embrase la scène
politique américaine et domine la
campagne présidentielle extrêmement
politisé l'épidémie n'en est pas
endiguée en octobre le bilan américain
dépasse 220 mille morts et 8 millions
d'infections
les etats unis restent donc les plus
touchés mais à la fin du mois ce titre
peut passer à l'inde elle grimpe à pas
géant le funeste podium et compte déjà
plus de 7,5 millions de cas ces deux
millions de plus qu'au brésil actuel
numéro 3 qui occupait la seconde place
il y a encore deux mois
rio est l'épicentre de l'épidémie en
amérique latine et le virus le frappe de
plein fouet
il est si meurtrier à son pic que le
brésil reste toujours le second pays le
plus endeuillé maintenant la flambée
ralenti mais elle a eu le temps
d'atteindre tout le continent qui compte
le plus d'infections et de morts dans le
monde
d'autres régions ont longtemps passé le
pic mais la trêve est de courte durée
en europe la deuxième vague bat son
plein de tous les nouveaux cas au monde
par jour un tiers vient du continent
européen
avec des records en france en grande
bretagne et on s
annie la plupart des pays du continent
européen re met donc en place des
restrictions des bars fermés plus tôt
travail à distance couvre-feu ou même
des villes bouclé comme madrid au cas
d'une montée incontrôlable pourtant
d'autres préfèrent l'option dur
ainsi en septembre le confinement total
revient à melbourne en australie et en
israël
s'il semble pourtant qu'une seconde
vague va renvoyer bientôt tout le monde
en confinement
la peur est ici paix par le ms car la
seconde vague mondiale n'existe pas et
en réalité les chiffres s'ajoutent à une
hausse continue sans encore ralentir sur
fond des flambées régionales il y à des
zones en nette baisse d'infection c'est
par exemple l'afrique région la moins
touchée
hormis la pacifique malgré l'état
déplorable de ses services sanitaires
face aux doutes sur ces chiffres
l'om s expliquent le succès africains
par le climat les particularités
régionales du génome et la réactivité
des autorités
pareilles en chine le berceau de
l'épidémie est à ce jour un des pays les
moins infectés
grâce à une réaction rapide et massive
au début de l'année le pays ramène
presque à zéro les contaminations d
avril
depuis la chine reprend la vie normale
tout en veillant sur le virus
la recette chinoise est vite reprise en
asie le vietnam la thaïlande et la
nouvelle zélande endigue rapidement la
maladie grâce à des stratégies de
maîtrise précoce du virus or même
lorsque le virus à maîtriser dans un
pays
il a peu de chances d'échapper aux
effets secondaires de la pandémie parmi
lesquels l'impact économique entre le
confinement en général et les frontières
fermées les plus fortes économies du
monde parte en chute libre
le second trimestre apporte une
récession profonde de l'inde jusqu'aux
états unis pour qui cette crise est la
pire depuis la grande dépression et son
effet sera bien palpable en 2020 la
récession fera monter le taux global
d'extrême pauvreté pour la première fois
après vingt ans de chute
ainsi près de 100 millions de personnes
devraient basculer dans l'extrême
pauvreté en 2020 et encore 150 millions
en 2021
d'après la banque mondiale est les
dégâts économiques causés par la
pandémie prive le mode de ressources au
moment où il en a le plus besoin surtout
pour élaborer un vaccin fiable
pourtant la course à la montre continue
et le premier qui l'emportera devra
d'abord passer par l'approbation de l'om
s avant de batailler pour sa
commercialisation
alors un vaccin universellement
certifier c'est pour bientôt on aura
besoin de vaccin et il ya un espoir
d'avoir peut-être un vaccin vers la fin
de l'année il y a un espoir
officiellement le ms ne privilégie aucun
des dix vaccins qui sont actuellement en
cours de finalisation
et même si un vaccin devait passer
toutes les étapes d'approbation avant
il ne serait pas immédiatement
accessible à tout le monde car le défi
logistique est énorme la tâche est en
effet colossal
très vite plusieurs milliards de doses
devront être produites dans le monde
une douzaine d'entreprises seulement
peuvent relever ce défi or avec les
capacités disponibles la production
d'une seule dose par habitant
s'étendrait sur quatre voire cinq ans la
logistique est un autre problème
important
la livraison par exemple certains
vaccins doivent rester congelé à moins
70 - 80 degrés
cette condition handicape lourdement
l'envoi du vaccin à vers les régions les
plus pauvres souvent au climat chaud
finalement les professionnels de
l'aviation estime que livrer les
8 milliards de doses sera le plus grand
défi de l'histoire des transports qui
devra mobiliser quelques 8000 à 15000
avions cargo pourtant au delà des
problèmes d'ordre purement pratique les
organisations internationales et
certains états lance un autre cri
d'alarmé il s'agit des brevets en effet
certains vaccins prometteurs comme par
exemple celui de modern art sont
protégées par des droits exclusifs
ce nationalisme vaccinale en rage les
médecins sans frontières il conviendra
de s'assurer que les brevets
savoir-faire et données liées à la
recherche et développement des vaccins
anti qu'ovide 19 sont effectivement
mises en commun à la disposition de tous
cette initiative trouve un écho chez les
dirigeants mondiaux les plus influents
si jean ping emmanuel macron angela
merkel ou encore antonio gutiérrez tous
sont d'accord sur une chose les formules
de traitement anti qu'ovide doivent
devenir le bien commun c'est de faire en
sorte dès maintenant qu'un vaccin contre
la copie de 19
lorsqu'il sera découvert bénéficier à
tous parce qu'il sera un bien public
mondial
l'appel du président français semble
être entendue en septembre dernier à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
une bonne dizaine de présidents en vo
qu'une solidarité transnationales face
au virus
le concept d'un vaccin accessible à tous
en tant que bien public mondial
enthousiasme surtout les petits pays en
effet l'égalité d'accès à ce traitement
est pour eux une question
particulièrement sensible et ils ont
bien raison de s'inquiéter
lors de l'épidémie de grippe a en 2009
les pays riches rachète toutes les doses
du nouveau vaccin et ne laisse rien au
pays les moins développés
est-ce que cela risque de se reproduire
en 2020 selon les ong oxfam
absolument oui d'ores et déjà une
poignée de pays et
et représentant 13% seulement de la
population mondiale ont déjà réservé
plus de la moitié de tous les vaccins en
développement contre le coc u19 la 2e
banque confirme 6 pi ont précommandé
bien plus qu'une dose par habitant
les méga stock britanniques américains
et canadiens suffiront pour vacciner
chaque citoyen cinq fois le japon et
l'union européenne talonne les leaders
et compte quatre vaccins pré commandé
par habitant et enfin l'australie entend
acheter trois doses par habitant d
appétit gargantuesque qui annonce une
nouvelle étape de la course au vaccin
mais cette fois pour l'acheter et
justement parmi les vaccins les plus
avancées quels sont les plus demandés
dans le monde et bien parmi les leaders
des commandes la société américano
allemande kaiser's biotech la
britannique astrazeneca la française
sanofi et deux firmes américaines
johnson & johnson et moderne à ces
vaccins occidentaux sont assez chers et
la plupart des précommandes vient
d'europe d'australie et d'amérique du
nord
cependant en dehors de ce club restreint
les vaccins à russes et chinois plus
accessible trouvent aussi leurs clients
selon moscou sont spoutnik mais le
premier vaccin contre le commis 19
annoncé au monde cumule déjà 1,2
milliard de précommande par une
cinquantaine d'états d'asie d'afrique de
l'amérique latine et du moyen-orient
avec quatre vaccins en dernière phase
d'essai la chine compte produire 610
millions de doses cette année et jusqu'à
1 milliard vers 2021 mais restent
discrètes sur leur destination
avec des dizaines d'autres vaccins
développés dans le monde le marché
présente malgré tout plusieurs options
pour les pays les plus pauvres et la
situation est bien différente d'il ya
dix ans pour garantir à 100% que chaque
pays reçoivent le traitement nécessaire
le nu l ems veulent en faire plus
élancée en dispositif mondial
ainsi née en avril 2020 à l'initiative
actes en forme longue ces accélérateurs
d'accès aux outils de kobe 19
son but est de fournir aux pays pauvres
tout le matériel
médicales nécessaires pour lutter contre
le corps n'avait russe l'aide est
financé par les 14 pays les plus
développés
l'union européenne et d'autres
organismes tels que la fondation bill
gates par exemple cependant ni
washington ni moscou ni ont adhéré aucun
des deux ne fait non plus partie du pays
et clef de l'acte
l'initiative kovacs axée sur les vaccins
et l'aide à la recherche à la production
de plusieurs projets afin d'obtenir un
vaccin universellement accessible autre
engagement clé le kovacs garantit à tous
les membres au moins 20% des vaccins
nécessaires pour leurs populations
un autre point important selon les
termes de kovacs les pays riches seront
obligés de partager leurs stocks avec
les pauvres plus de 170 pays se sont
engagés auprès de kovacs dont la chine
depuis très récemment
pour mieux comprendre cette course au
vaccin nous rejoignons à nouveau natale
et comptines et économise de la santé à
l'université sorbonne-paris nord madame
continue aujourd'hui plus de 150 500 à
tiko vides sont en cours de
développement le monde at il vraiment
besoin d'une telle quantité non bien sûr
mais nous n'avons pas besoin de 150
vaccins un seul ne suffirait le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya différentes
technologies qui sont traitées pour
trouver un vaccin qui a beaucoup d'
équipes de recherche qui se sont lancés
et qu'on met tout finalement un essai de
mettre toutes les chances de notre côté
pour trouver ce vaccin est donc
différente quand dans différents
candidats vaccins ont été étudiés alors
y en a 150 effectivement mais il y en a
qu'une dizaine qui est en phase de test
donc dans phase de test 3 c'est à dire
sur grande porte et donc ce sont sans
doute dans ces dix là on trouvera le
vaccin ou les vaccins parce qu'il est
possible que l'on ait plusieurs vaccins
et plusieurs générations de vaccins une
première génération peut-être pas très
efficace et puis progressivement une
deuxième ou une troisième génération de
vaccins plus efficaces et qui est le
favori de cette course selon vous qui
sera gagné les parts de marché
rapidement à c'est très difficile à dire
parce que certains communiquent beaucoup
les américains
on modern à communique beaucoup on sait
qu'en chine il ya déjà dédé des
populations qui sont vaccinés avec un
vaccin
donc c'est difficile parce que le niveau
d'information qui est diffusée par les
uns et les autres n'est pas tout à fait
de même mais vraisemblablement on peut
considérer que les américains sont assez
avancés que astrazeneca l'européen est
aussi assez avancé et donc je ne
parierai pas sur le gagnant mais disons
qu'on a on a quand même quelques acteurs
qui semblent très avancé dans cette
recherche d'un vaccin et enfin dans
certains pays le nombre de vaccins pré
commandes et attend même 5 par habitant
à quoi ça sert et comment lutter contre
ça et en laisser une partie aux pays
plus pauvres alors effectivement il ya
beaucoup de pays qui ont commandé
différents fin des vaccins à différentes
firmes
c'est sans doute aussi pour se prémunir
c'est l'idée de pas mettre ses oeufs
dans le même panier
et comme personne ne peut dire
aujourd'hui celui qui va gagner et bien
beaucoup de pays notamment les pays
européens ont acheté ont pré commandé
des vaccins à différents acteurs aux
acteurs qui sont les plus susceptibles
selon te de trouver rapidement à max 1
donc c'est plutôt l'idée de ne pas
commander car une firme est de prendre
le risque que ce ne soit pas elle qui
trouve les plus tôt de commander à
plusieurs firmes alors l'europe a aussi
commandé beaucoup de vaccins dans l'idée
de pouvoir qu'un des réserves aussi pour
les pays du sud qui ne pourraient pas en
avoir
est-ce que effectivement ces vaccins ce
moment donné aux pays du sud
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est ce
qui a été annoncé par la présidente de
la commission européenne merci beaucoup
et nathalie cotisé je rappelle vous êtes
économiste de la santé à l'université
sorbonne-paris nord merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission et d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage cette partie là
n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]